ابو اليمن يضعون ابسط حل لمرور السفن
بامان في البحر الاحمر وطائره امريكا
وبريطانيا تقصف صنعاء بينما تلبيب تنشئ
محورا بحريا جديدا لتفادي هجمات الجيش
اليمني ايطاليا تكشف الهدف من العمليه
العسكريه في البحر الاحمر والكست يجتمع
لحجب الثقه عن حكومه النتنياهو فيما تل
ابيب تقدم مقترحا للتهدئه مع الفصائل مصر
تنفي تهريب الاسلحه للقطاع وتعلن دفن 1500
نفق وخيبه امل بر يه من الحكومه العبريه
مع تصدعات واضحه بين تل ابيب وحلفائها
الغربيين حرب لبنان تقترب وتل ابيب تناشد
دول العالم وهنغاريا للاتحاد الاوروبي
تسليح اوكرانيا هلوسه عسكريه قديمه لن
تجلب سوى الدمار سلوفاكيا ترفض انضمام
اوكرانيا للناتو وموسكو تعلن استعدادها
للتفاوض بشان اوكرانيا وبولندا تعلنها
للاوكراني بالمجان وعليكم دفع
الفاتوره السفن تقبل الشرط
الحوثي بعد ان اعلن الجيش اليمني استهداف
سفينه الشحن العسكريه الامريكيه اوشن جاز
بخليج عدن ورغم ان الجيش الامريكي انكر
هذه العمليه فان الولايات المتحده
وبريطانيا قامت بتنفيذ عده الضربات وغارات
جويه على عده اهداف مع تحليق كثيف للطيران
في العاصمه اليمنيه صنعاء بعد عده ساعات
من بيان الجيش اليمني
[موسيقى]
ولنتصور
وكانت حكومه صنعاء قد وضعت شرطا واحدا وها
هي السفن تستجيب في البحر الاحمر وقال عضو
المجلس السياسي الاعلى لحكومه صنعاء محمد
علي الحوثي في منشور له عبر منصه اكس ان
ابسط حل يسمح بمرور السفن بامان اثناء
عبورها من البحر الاحمر هو ان تضع عباره
لا علاقه لنا بتلابيب في لوحه التعريف
الالي الخاصه بها مضيفا ان هذا الحل اثبت
فاعليته ان عبرت البحر 64 سفينه بامان وهي
تضع هذه العباره بينما اتهم ابو اليمن
الولايات المتحده باستغلال الاحداث في
البحر الاحمر لتضليل الراي العام الدولي
عبر خلق ازمه لتحميل صنعاء تبعاتها بخدمه
تلبيب وحذرت حكومه صنعاء واشنطن من مغبه
تاثير مصالح اليمن جراء قرار تصنيفهم
منظمه ارهابيه هناك اكد وزير الخارجيه
الايطالي انطونيو تاجاني ان الهدف من
المهمه العسكريه الاوروبيه في البحر
الاحمر هو حمايه حركه الملاحه من المسيرات
والصواريخ ولن تهاجم الاراضي اليمنيه فيما
كانت وزيره المواصلات العبريه ميري ريغيف
قالت في بيان نشرته بحسابها على منصه اكس
ان العمل جار على انشاء محور لنقل البضائع
من الهند عبر الامارات ومنها الى تل ابيب
للالتفاف على هجمات الجيش اليمني في البحر
الاحمر وافادت صحيفه نيويورك تايمز بان
مسؤولين امريكيين وبريطانيين واوروبي
يمارسون ضغوطا على تلب للسماح بدخول
المساعدات الانسانيه الى القطاع عبر ميناء
اشدود وفي الداخل العبري افادت القناه 12ث
العبريه بان الكست اجتمع لمناقشه اقتراح
حجب الثقه عن حكومه النتنياهو بعد فشلها
في اعاده الرهائن من
القطاع بينما قال وزير الدفاع البريطاني
جراند تابس ان رفض رئيس الوزراء العبري حل
الدولتين مخيب للغايه لكنه ليس مفاجئا
واكد تابس ان بلاده لا ترى طريقا اخر
لانهاء الصراع سوى حل الدولتين بدوره ذكر
موقع اكسيوس الامريكي نقلا عن مسؤولين
عبريين لم يكشف عن هويتهما ان حكومه تلبيب
قدمت عرضا للفصائل عبر وسطاء قطريين
ومصريين من اجل تبادل الرهائن مقابل وقف
الحرب لمده قد تصل لشهرين اثنين غربيا
تحدثت صحيفه الاندبندنت عن تصدعات واضحه
بين تلبيب وحليفته ما الولايات المتحده
وبريطانيا تنعكس في تصريحات المسؤولين
بشان اقامه الدولتين الفلسطينيه وفي
افتتاحيه ها ارتس رات ان الحل الوحيده
للصراع العبري مع الفصائل هو الدفع نحو
اقامه الدوله الفلسطينيه وابعاد النتنياهو
في مصر وفي بيان صادر عن ضياء راشوان رئيس
هيئه الاستعلامات المصريه الرسميه اكد فيه
ان اي تحرك عبر في اتجاه احتلال ممر
فيلاديلفيا او صلاح الدين في القطاع سيؤدي
الى تهديد خطير وجدي للعلاقات المصريه
العبريه مكذبا مزاعمه الابي باتهام مصر
بتهريب السلاح للقطاع ووفق ما نقلته وسائل
اعلام مصريه قال رشوان ان القاهره اقامت
منطقه عازله بطول 5 كيلومترات من مدينه
رفح المصريه وحتى الحدود مع القطاع وتم
تدمير اكثر من 1500 نفق كما قامت ببناء
جدار خرساني بطول 6ه امتار فوق الارض وسته
امتار تحت الارض فاصبحت هناك ثلاثه حواجز
بين سيناء ورفح يستحيل منها اي عمليه
تهريب لا فوق الارض ولا من تحتها وفق
البيان المصري ولنضع لكم المصدر منطقه
عازله بطول 5 ك متر خلي بالكم الكلام ده
مهم ودقيق 5 كيلو متر من مدينه رفح
المصريه وحتى الحدود مع غزه وتم تدمير
خلوا بالكم ده كلام قوي قوي اكتر من 1500
نفق في لبنان اكد وزير الدفاع العبري اف
جالانت ان تلبيب لن توقف اطلاق النار حتى
ولو اوقفته المقاومه اللبنانيه محذرا من
ان الحرب ستكون صعبه لتل ابيب لكنها مدمره
بالنسبه للمقاومه وللبنان وكانت القناه
ال3 العبريه نقلت عن وزير الخارجيه العبري
بان الحرب في لبنان ستكون وشيكه ان لم يتم
الضغط لابعاد المقاومه عن الحدود بعيدا عن
الشرق الاوسط افادت صحيفه ول ستريت جورنال
بان استطلاعات الراي العام في ولايه
متشيغان تشير الى مصاعب يواجهها الرئيس جو
بايدن تجعل اعاده انتخابه في خطر وذكرت
الصحيفه ان الصراع في القطاع ادى الى نفور
بعض الناخبين الشبابي والامريكيين العربي
في متشيغان وان استطلاعات الراي تظهر ان
ترامب يكتسح الدعم بين الناخبين السود
وقالت ان نشطاء الحزب الديمقراطي يشيرون
الى وجود تحالف متعدد الاعراق لدعم
الفلسطينيين في القطاع ويشعرون بالقلق من
ان الصراع مطول قد يضر بفرص
بايدن استبداد
داخلي تصدع داخلي اوكراني قد يجبر الغرب
على تغيير سياسه مع كياب فقد قال عمده كيا
فيتالي كوتشيكو ان اوكرانيا تتحرك في
الاتجاه الخاطئ مضيفا انها تصبح دوله
استبداد اكثر فاكثر واشار كلوتش كو في
حوار مع صحيفه جلوب اند ميل الكنديه الى
ان منتق فلاديمير زيلينسكي يتعرضون للضغط
من جهته قال رئيس وزراء سلوفاكيا روبرت
فيسو ان اوكرانيا المجاوره ليست دوله ذات
سياده لكنها تخضع للسيطره المطلقه من
الولايات المتحده مؤكدا رفضه تقديم
مساعدات عسكريه لكيف او فرض عقوبات على
روسيا مع معارضته انضمام اوكرانيا الى حلف
الناتو وهنا المصدر يتحدث قال رئيس وزراء
سلوفاكيا في تصريحات ان كيف ليست دوله ذات
سياده متهما اوكرانيا بانها تحت السيطره
الامريكيه واكد المسؤول السلوفاكي معارضته
انضمام اوكرانيا الى حلف شمال الاطلسي
موضحا موقفه المناهض لعضويه كيف في النيتو
اقتصاديا وصف وزير الخارجيه الهنغاري بيتر
سيارتو على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
اقتراح رصد الاتحاد الاوروبي 5 مليارات
يورو سنويا لتسليح اوكرانيا بانها هلوسه
عسكريه قديمه لن تجذب سوى الدمار وكانت
صحيفه بايس افادت نقلا عن وثيقه من اداره
العلاقه الخارجيه بالاتحاد الاوروبي بان
ديون الاتحاد الاوروبي تراكمت على الاتحاد
امام دول اعضاء فيه ارساله الاسلحه
لاوكرانيا لتصل الى
7.16 مليار يورو هنا صرح رئيس الوزراء
البولندي دونالد توسك بان بولندا لم تعد
قادره على امداد اوكرانيا بالاسلحه مجانا
وستقدم المساعدات العسكريه لقوات كياف على
اساس تجاري ليصرح الرئيس الاوكراني
فلاديمير زيلنسكي على موقع اكس عقب اجتماع
مع رئيس الوزراء البولندي بان كياف ستشتري
اسلحه من بولندا مقابل قروض مشيرا الى ان
هذا سيصبح شكلا جديدا من اشكال تعاون
البلدين ليعلن وزير الدفاع الاوكراني
روستوم يروف على موقع اكس ان بلجيكا ستقدم
لاوكرانيا مساعدات عسكريه بقيمه 611 مليون
يورو هذا العام هذا وذكرت صحيفه بوليتيكو
نقلا عن رئيس الوزراء السلوفاكي روبرت
فيكو انه من اجل انهاء الصراع في اوكرانيا
يتعين على كياف ان تتخلى على الاراضي
لموسكو وميدانيا اعلنت وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه تكبيد الجيش الاوكراني اكثر من
1005 عسكريين بين قتيل وجريح واسقاط طائره
سو 25 و76 مسيره اوكرانيه على مخت في
المحاور خلال 24 ساعه فيما صرح مفوض
السياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي
جوزي بوريل بان الهجوم المضاد الاوكراني
لم يحقق النتائج المرجوه داعيا الى احياء
الصناعه الدفاعيه الاوروبيه هناك صرح وزير
الخارجيه الروسي سيرغي لافروف بان روسيا
مستعده لاجراء مفاوضات بشان اوكرانيا ولكن
ليس حول كيفيه ابقاء زعماء ال كياف
الحاليين في السلطه مشيرا الى ان ما يسمى
بصيغه زيلينسكي للسلام وغيرها من الصيغ
المماثله لا تؤدي الى اي حل وكلما اسرعت
الولايات المتحده والاتحاد الاوروبي في
ادراك ذلك كان ذلك افضل بالنسبه لهما
لتفيد صحيفه زد دي اف الالمانيه بانه
يتعين على الجيش الاوكراني مغادره الاراضي
بسبب النقص الحدي في الذخيره وعدم القدره
على صد هجمات الجيش الروسي مشيره الى ان
الجيش الروسي يتمكن من التقدم في اتجاه
كوبيانسك وتحرير كرخ م لنوي في مقاطعه
خاركوف
[موسيقى]